. We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a question via a voicemail
about the swearing in of Amy CONI
Barrett that I actually received from
a number of people. Take a listen.
The David Pakman Show. Who are you? Hey, so
Courtney, very good. But what's interesting is why
is Clarence Thomas Square then versus
the chief justice? What's that about?
Yeah. You know, a lot of people ask this.
Typically, it would be the chief justice swearing
in, you know, a president, a new Supreme Court
justice, etc., which would be John Roberts. John
Roberts didn't do the swearing in of Amy Koney
Barrett. It was Clarence Thomas Thomas instead.
Now, I did a bunch of research to see if there
was anything definitive about why that was. I
wasn't able to find anything other than a
lot of people speculating. And the primary
speculation was John Roberts takes more seriously,
avoiding what looked like politicized events and
a haphazardly thrown together nighttime event at
the White House during a 100 year global pandemic
may have rub rub John Roberts more the wrong
way than it rubbed Clarence Thomas the wrong
way. And that's the consensus speculation that I
found, although I've found nothing definitive. And
maybe we'll learn something more about
that upcoming. But yes, many of you
and I and many others wondering aloud about what
the deal was with that. On today's bonus show, we
will talk about Russia ordering a national mask.
Mandate coronavirus is out of control in Russia.
We will talk about those two right wing
operatives, Jacob Wall and Jack Burkman, indicted
in a second state for voter suppression schemes.
I thought it was the left that was going to do
the voter fraud. And a Michigan judge has
struck down a ban on the open carrying of
guns at polling places on Election Day.
All of those stories and more on
today's Bonas show get instant access by
becoming a member at join Pacman dot com.